- [Mark Trent] Nothing has
been so true in my career
as shoot what I know, and
what I know is West Virginia.
There's something about
this state and the people
that live here, and the
generosity that happens.
People aren't afraid to
roll up their sleeves
and help their neighbors,
people aren't afraid
to pick you up when you fall.
My name is Mark Trent.
I don't wanna say follow my
dreams, because that's...
We'll get this.
I used to work in New
York making commercials.
I was traveling all the
time, I was living the dream,
I guess, but I was working
on some personal work
in my home state of West
Virginia that involves
prescription drug abuse in the region.
That's one of the reasons
why I bought my Subaru,
I had to get down to West Virginia more,
that was my goal.
There came a point where I had to choose
between my life in New
York and my life here,
and I chose my life here.
So when I moved back to
West Virginia, I came here
to kind of focus on the projects
that I was passionate about
and when the flood happened,
everything was put on hold.
It was the worst flood
in West Virginia history,
in a sense, and it happened
in a matter of minutes.
I mean, people didn't
notice until it was too late
and they were trapped in their homes.
After the storm, people from everywhere,
all over the country came to help.
That was one of the
most surprising things,
the way people just banded together.
I'd lived in New York for so
many years, I'd lost my sense
of community, and then just coming
home and seeing that love
and that support, no one that
needed anything went without
during the flood.
My Subaru, it's a part of my tool-set
that's just as important as my cameras.
I wanted a car that I
could load my equipment in
and travel around.
As soon as I saw the five-door
Imprezas, I was like "yeah."
I knew that this was gonna work.
I appreciate the fact that
Subaru cares about the people
that I care about, people like
the people in my community
that they help.
I'm doing a new film
about the flood recovery.
Hopefully this documentary
will be my biggest contribution
to the flood relief,
because as time progresses,
people forget, and I want
to sort of remind everybody
that this stuff is still happening.
Hey, Ronnie!
How are you doing?
- I'm behind ya, buddy, it gets tougher.
- [Mark] Being back in West
Virginia has definitely
facilitated my passion
projects again, I'm actually
present in the state and
I can make work here,
and I can talk about it.
I'm not just dipping in
for a few days at a time.
For me, it's not going out for a few hours
and taking pictures, it's
days and maybe months.
It's presence, it's
patience, it's honesty,
it's a commitment, and
you're not just there
to get a picture, you're
there to learn about somebody.